check your calendar check your phone
you'll notice that it's April 20th also
known as 420 The Unofficial cannabis
holiday yeah or official well I think
it's almost official now at this point
here in our city joining us to talk
about the growing popularity of cannabis
experiences here in our city Maxine
fence and the founder of Las Vegas
Cannabis tours Maxine welcome you guys
do all kinds of things including like um
tours and weddings and it is all about
celebrating this culture which is legal
and and um happy 420 and it's growing
right it's a growing uh industry so yes
it is so we're doing uh seeds seeds and
weight package for 420 and Earth Day and
basically if you would like to do one of
our tours we will take you to do glass
blowing then I'll take you to lunch and
then I'll take you to my favorite
dispensary and then we get on a
helicopter and then off we go and go
over the Las Vegas Strip so totally
fabulous wow 420 okay so for you get a
helicopter popped our tour you get to go
to a dispensary have lunch yes 420 and
plastic you get to blow glass as well
and also there's a component Earth Day
is on Saturday folks so you guys are
doing what seats for wheat and it's how
many trees per person uh it's full one
tree planted and for every tool that we
sell 25 trays get planted so it's it's a
nice thing and it fits in you know we
were talking before we started about the
Cannabis tourism industry in Las Vegas
they're trying to get these lounges
going but the industry overall with
legal marijuana in Las Vegas how's
business these days oh it's pretty brisk
there's a lot of demand yeah there is
absolutely yeah
talk about that you said all likes walks
of life and some folks at home may be
saying who are the users and I think
sometimes you know we joke and say yeah
man but it's all different uh it
encompasses everything like I've taken
people three generations grandmother
mother daughter father and son people
who work in hospitals who you know work
you know in shops like students
everybody once again it's a whole whole
yeah it's a lifestyle and and lots of
different people from all walks of life
so what are some other specials for 420
uh that people can take part yes okay uh
well Nobu are giving away a purple
Ferrari today that I want to win but you
haven't spent 200 okay with LV Exotics
to be in the in the draw for that also
Planet 13 are giving five thousand
dollars cash if you buy online today or
in the shop you go in for the draw for
five thousand and then also Jade at
their Sky Point dispensary they are
giving away a one uh sorry a eighth for
one penny if you donate a pint of blood
which by the way helps three people
you can do so much good with all of
these I mean absolutely blood for folks
you could plant trees
who knew that 420 could have so many
different what a holiday
Inn on our website so folks if you want
to sign up for one of these tours you
can find it here 6 26